- I asked Jimmy and Maya
whenever they were here,
memories of Prince, you know,
because I heard about the huge
40th anniversary SNL party.
And it sounds like the most epic party
in all of the lands.
- Yeah.
So what do you remember about that night?
- Well, I mean, it was
the party that only exists
in like works of fiction.
We never would have that
many people together again,
but I remember my wife and I
were weaving through the crowd.
Right as Prince was on stage.
And it's very strange,
you never think of like
famous people going like this,
"Excuse me, excuse me."
(Kelly laughs)
But it was so densely packed
and I was doing the excuse me
and then just came like,
you know, my face came
like this close to Beyonce
and I, we were, you know, we,
our eyes met and I just was like,
"Pretty cool party, right?
(audience laughs)
And she said, "Yeah."
And then we just kept going,
like the momentum took us away.
(Kelly laughing)
And my wife said,
"Wow, you really, really
killed that interaction."
(Kelly laughing)
- Hi!
She then she said, "Hi."
- You better leave
your ringer on
- And I said, "Hi."
- Cause you're probably
going to get a call
from Beyonce.
- She said "Hi," then I said "Hi,"
and then it was over.
It was awesome.
- I said, I dunno if you heard,
I was like "Pretty cool party, right?"
And then she was like, "Yeah."
And like, I went pretty good.
(Kelly laughing)